I'm just gonna say it,
but being a stay at home mom is easy.
Can we just say that being a mom,
period, is hard work?
It's not easy.
Working mom,
stay at home mom,
they're both hard jobs.
Because being a parent is a hard job.
Having a three day weekend
is not the same as being a full time stay at home mom.
It's just. It's not.
It's like apples to oranges.
You have multiple people in your home helping you,
which most stay at home moms don't have.
You can get all your tasks done in a day
because you're not doing enough.
You're doing the bare minimum
of what it takes to run a home efficiently.
Um, and that's fine.
Like, sometimes the bare minimum
in certain seasons of life is needed,
especially if you've just had a baby.
But being a stay at home mom
is much more than just doing your daily chores
and keeping your kid healthy,
safe, and happy.
I don't like speaking on parenting topics personally
because I only have one child
who is almost a year and a half old,
and she, ha ha,
is very different than what she was when she was
six months old.
Extremely different.
Very defiant,
has a fiery spirit.
I like it in her. But, um,
no, they're not the same.
Different seasons of life come,
and you will learn that
when they're able to walk and get into things
and do all the Things that the toddler stage brings. Um.
You might change your tune.